bonjour et bienvenue dans le roc de
votre rendez vous européen des chaînes
parlementaires
cette semaine nous allons parler
immigration katia oui n'aura nous irons
notamment à la frontière gréco turque où
se pressent les migrants venus
principalement d'afghanistan et du
pakistan en réponse la grèce a décidé de
construire un mur mais d'abord la
polémique
à l'heure où l'europe vieillit faut-il
fermer les frontières et refuse à
l'immigration c'est la question que nous
posons cette semaine c'était ce dimanche
au creux de la nuit à lampedusa
ils sont des centaines à bord dont des
femmes et des enfants
tous n'ont pas été sauvée ils fuient la
guerre ou cherche du travail
mais en ce moment en europe la
ritournelle c'est circulez on ferme à
vintimille on piétine la solidarité le
droit des migrants et d'asile sur
l'autel de la sécurité objectif stopper
l'invasion côté commission on temporise
on rassure on égratigne schengen
d'accord mais non promis juré on ne veut
pas faire de l'europe une surcote mais
il ne vaudrait mieux pas non à l'heure
où la vieille europe voit sa population
des cas tirs
comment maintenir la sacro sainte
croissance
l'allemagne est déjà dans un état
d'urgence démographique et en 2030 la
population européenne commencera à
décliner
alors sans l'immigration que faire
bâtiment restauration garde d'enfants
informatique
combien de secteurs d'activité serait en
panne sans immigrés pour garantir la
croissance et le paiement des
prestations sociales ocde estime qu'il
faudrait 13 millions d'immigrés par an
d'ici à 2050
alors faut-il vraiment réformer schengen
la réforme de schengen une question qui
fait polémique
aujourd'hui en europe et pour en parler
nous recevons harlem désir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes donc députés
européens socialistes démocrates et
numéro deux du parti socialiste français
alors selon vous est ce que vraiment
cette réforme est utile bonjour non je
ne le crois pas je crois qu évidemment
on peut toujours perfectionner des
outils comme schengen mais d'abord
schengen c'est un grand acquis pour les
européens c'est cet espace de liberté de
circulation des personnes qui montre que
l'europe n'est pas justement qu'un
marché n'est pas qu'un espace de liberté
de circulation des marchandises
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une crise en
italie avec l'arrivée à lampedusa de
réfugiés les uns venant de tunisie
d'autres venant de libye mais qui est
liée non pas un problème de gestion de
l'immigration ordinaire en europe mais à
des événements exceptionnels qui sont
positifs d'ailleurs en soi qui se sont
produits en tunisie à une guerre civile
ça ça n'est pas positif
exactement quand on ne peut pas le dire
que l est un événement anodin puisque
nous mêmes nous sommes engagés en libye
et qui provoque donc des fuites de
population civile mais il faut dire que
la jeune tunisie libre et le pays qui
aujourd'hui accueille le plus de
réfugiés qui sont bien deux cent
soixante ans de lumière donc je crois
que la réponse européenne ça devrait
certainement évidemment de se porter à
l'aide de l'italie
parce que c'est la proximité
géographique qui fait qu'elles
accueillent ces tunisiens où ces libyens
qui débarque mais qu'en fait ils
essayent de venir trouver refuge en
europe donc il ya eu un manque de
réaction et de solidarité européenne et
ça aurait été beaucoup plus digne que ce
sommet des populistes damon démagogique
de sarkozy et de berlusconi qui se
rejetaient les migrants par delà la
frontière franco tunisienne comme des
paquets de linge sale selon vous il ya
un devoir de solidarité entre les pays
européens sur cette question où est ce
que c'est à la grèce qui a également des
frontières
à l'extrême ou à l'italie de gérer ses
propres frontières il y a un devoir de
solidarité d'autant qu'il est vrai que
comme il y à cette espace de libre
circulation qui échangent gun il y a le
principe du contrôle des frontières
extérieures communes et que donc quand
un migrant est accueilli en italie ou en
grèce
ensuite il doit pouvoir circuler
librement donc si on estime que ça va
être difficile pour l'italie où pour la
grèce de faire face à cet afflux
migrants il faut les aider il faut les
aider à accueillir d'abord sur le plan
humanitaire à traiter ces dossiers à
voir comment s'il ya des réfugiés
accueillir en europe on les accueille
collectivement par en disant que les
grecs se débrouille ou que les italiens
se débrouille vingt mille réfugiés
tunisiens à l'échelle des 500 millions
d'habitants de l'union européenne c'est
possible c'est beaucoup moins d'ailleurs
que les réfugiés qui sont arrivés par
exemple après les guerres dans les
balkans après la guerre du kosovo après
la guerre entre la croatie et la serbie
ça a été des centaines de milliers de
personnes qu'il a fallu accueillir mais
avery est parvenu en termes pratiques
comment est ce que on gère ensuite ces
migrants on les accueille vous je sais
que vous prenez vous vous prenez la
possibilité de leur offrir l'asile de
mettre en place des camps etc
mais ensuite qu'est ce qu'on fait il
faut que nous ayons une approche
rationnelle de ces situations il faut
arrêter de parler d'invasion il y à des
situations d'instabilité
on l'a évoqué créée par la guerre en
libye par la révolution en tunisie
il faut d'abord faire en sorte que la
situation puisse se stabiliser dans ces
pays ce que souhaite la tunisie et les
tunisiens
c'est demain que l'avenir soit soit plus
viable c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait un
développement économique il y est parce
qu il y aura la fin de la dictature et
de la corruption
davantage de possibilités pour
l'épanouissement des habitants de ce
pays donc et dont par exemple par une
sorte de plan marshall européen en
direction de la tunisie
demain je l'espère en direction de la
libye quant à la situation militaire
sera terminée qu'on sera sorti de la
guerre une aide au redémarrage
économique par exemple le tourisme en
tunisie qui fournissait à peu près 3
millions d'emplois évidemment est en
crise très profonde et dont à ce que les
touristes européens y compris puisse
revenir mais ça suppose que d'ici là la
situation plus critique sur la question
des réfugiés
et des immigrés clandestins qu'est-ce
qu'on fait demain vous le imaginons que
demain faisant un petit peu de politique
fiction et de prévision le candidat ps
aux élections présidentielles françaises
soient élus qu'est ce que vous faites
pour cette question là est-ce que vous
reviendrez sur cette réforme de schengen
ou est-ce que vous procéderez à des
régularisations massives comme on l'a vu
dans le sujet l'oscd eux prévoient qu'il
faudrait 13 millions d'immigrés par an
pour maintenir notre niveau de
développement qu'est ce qu'on fait oui
c'est pour ça que je crois quand même il
faut distinguer bon les tunisiens à qui
l'italie a donné des titres de séjour
ils sont pas en situation irrégulière il
ya une contestation de la part du
gouvernement français du fait que
l'italie lors et délivrer des titres de
séjour ce sont des titres de séjour
provisoires qui sont censés leur
permettent de résider sur le territoire
italien ou européens le temps que la
situation se stabilise en tunisie est
donc encore une fois la réponse il faut
la porter en termes de stabilisation de
redémarrage économique en tunisie par
exemple nous nous avons proposé que pour
un grand nombre d'entre eux on met en
oeuvre un accord franco tunisien qui
prévoyait conforme 9000 jeunes tunisiens
tous les ans dans un certain nombre de
nos universités en particulier à dijon
d'ailleurs pour que ils profitent de
leur séjour en france ou en europe pour
acquérir de meilleures qualifications ça
les aidera quand ils retourneront dans
leur pays je crois que la plupart
veulent retourner dans leur pays
il y a par ailleurs des règles pour
l'immigration donc évidemment que quand
la gauche vous me demandez ce que ferait
un gouvernement de gauche quand la
gauche reviendra aux responsabilités ce
que je souhaite ce à quoi nous
travaillons
il y aura des règles il faut à la fois
que l'immigration se passe dans des
cadres légaux que les gens qui immigrent
de façon légale parce que votre
reportage de monterey on a besoin d'un
certain nombre de secteurs la
construction l'agriculture encore
l'hôtellerie la restauration d'une main
d'oeuvre étrangère dans des domaines où
on trouve pas à embaucher en france même
s'il faut aussi encourager les gens qui
sont au chômage en france à se former et
à travailler dans ces secteurs il faut
que les gens soient en situation
régulière soit intégrée et qu'ils soient
n'ont pas exposé à l'immigration
illégale
il ya des gens si de reconduite à la
frontière des gens qui ne sont pas en
situation légale évidemment peuvent être
reconduits à la frontière
donc la gauche demande à la fois que
parfois on procède à des régularisations
je pense aussi à des cas que défend
réseau éducation sans frontières
deux familles dont les enfants sont
scolarisés dont les parents travaillent
dont ils ont payé les uns pour les
cotisations sociales parfois depuis 8 9
10 ans mais qui ne sont pas régularisés
parce que les employeurs n'ont pas fait
les déclarations parce que aussi parfois
la législation n'a pas été adapté il
faut dans ce cas là procéder à une
régularisation
parce qu'il ya une véritable insertion
et envoie les familles les parents
d'élèves se mobiliser pour cette
régularisation et dans d'autres cas il
ya des gens qui ont pas vocation à
rester et qui seront reconduits à la
frontière mais ça c'est indépendant de
la situation de crise où on a des
réfugiés les réfugiés on doit les
accueillir et les aider et les traités
dignement en aidant à ce que la
situation de leur pays d'origine leur
permettent de retourner dans leur pays
au plus tôt harlem désir merci et on
continue sur cette question c'est celle
ci dessous s'est emparé de cette
question et a été voir un petit peu
comment les télévisions européennes chez
nos voisins ont traité la polémique sur
l'immigration
des images choc des drames de
l'immigration vue sur toutes les télés
européennes leurs provenances l'île de
lampedusa où l'on en parle avec émotion
à la fin quand on nous a dit c'est fini
nous nous sommes tombés dans les bras et
quand nous avons appris aujourd'hui
qu'ils étaient tous vivants tous tous
les 300 ça a été un des moments les plus
beaux de notre vie on apprendra plus
tard qu'ils étaient plus de 500 sur
l'embarcation et on dénombre trois morts
en france triste bilan aussi comme
l'expliquent ce journaliste de la bbc
qui était allé voir ce qui se passait
sur le terrain
si beaucoup de ces jeunes hommes
rentrent en tunisie ce n'est pas
seulement le gouvernement français qui
sera soulagé mais toute l'europe où l'on
a peur que ces révolutions arabes
déclenchant un afflux massif d'immigrés
en plus ils arriveront démunis sans rien
sur la zdf
on va plus loin et on s'interroge sur le
poids économique de l'immigration légale
une grande partie de la deuxième
génération à moins de 20 ans ils sont à
la maternelle à l'école en formation et
coûte donc cher à la société
dans cinq à dix ans beaucoup d'entre eux
arriveront sur le marché du travail et
peyron des impôts à face à ce qu'ils
considèrent être un afflux les belges
comptent durcir leur politique en
matière de regroupement familial et
doivent faire face à quelques petits
problèmes
en effet un belge mariée à un étranger
pourrait se retrouver défavorisés par
rapport à un immigré s'il souhaite faire
venir sa famille dont le texte proposé
les belges ne sont pas traités égalité
avec les européens donc un bulgare ou un
roumain aura des conditions d'accès plus
favorable qu'un belge et sa pelouse
totalement inacceptable
voilà et nous avons été rejoint sur ce
plateau par kayhan karaca bonjour vous
êtes journaliste turc et spécialiste des
questions européennes pour la télévision
ntv
vous voyez un petit peu toute cette
polémique sur l'immigration légale
illégale en europe
quelle est votre lecture en fait de ces
événements bah écoutez moi même comme
toutes les chaînes d'informations en
turquie nous suivons de très près ce qui
se passe concernant l'immigration
clandestine est légale en europe puisque
la turquie fait partie en fait non pas
pour l'instant de l'union européenne
mais de la famille européenne donc
l'actualité européenne où nous intéresse
de très près vous êtes un partenaire
privilégié absolument
si vous voulez y en a qui aiment pas se
taire si vous le souhaitez
sucré
bon ça concerne la turquie puisqu'il ya
beaucoup de
des migrations aussi d'origine turque en
europe
et puis bon ça concerne un petit peu
aussi la turquie puis même si on ne
parle pas actuellement de l'adula
turquie la turquie et les frontalières
avec certains pays de l'union européenne
l'agressé et la bulgarie
donc vous êtes concerné par ce problème
est ce que ça vous choque ce traitement
comment est ce que vous le est-ce que
vous considérez qu'on en fait beaucoup
trop est ce que c'est une problématique
en fait sur laquelle les européens ont
tendance à se figer à ne pas en sortir
est ce que comme comment est-ce que vous
la voyez
personnellement ça me choque en tant que
qu'individu puisque personne ne parle
par exemple dans ce dans cette crise de
réfugiés tunisiens ou de candidats à
l'émigration tunisien qu' il ya eu 200
plus de 200 mille tunisiens qui
travaillaient en libye qui ont dû
rentrer chez eux en en tunisie
et ici en europe ont fait une telle
crise à cause de 20000 enfin c'est ce
qu'on dit mais le candidat à
l'immigration tunisien je veux dire de
ce point de vue là ça me choque mais il
faut aussi voir ce qui se passe dans ces
pays du nord du continent africain il ya
un manque de solidarité selon vous entre
l'europe et ses voisins de méditerranée
absolument oui mais ça c'est pas un
problème qui date d'aujourd'hui c'est un
programme qui date de
de plusieurs années et
plusieurs villes la plupart des
spécialistes européenne en matière de
démographie et d'immigration propose la
création étape par étape d'une zone de
libre circulation euro-méditerranéenne
je pense que là réside la solution mais
par exemple on a un problème par exemple
à la frontière gréco turque sur la
rivière evros dont on va parler un petit
peu plus tard là haut dans un reportage
qui va diffuser
est-ce que vous pensez que la turquie
fin est ce que le gouvernement turc se
sont soutenus par l'europe sur ces
questions ou est ce qu'il ya un abandon
de la question des fronts des frontières
extérieures
ce sujet tant interne de sujets des
dialogues entre l'union européenne et la
turquie
il s'agit d'un
de la signature d'un accord de
réadmission entre la turquie et l'union
européenne
mais là on revient à la même chose entre
les pays de méditerranée la turquie et
l'union européenne
lorsque vous demander des efforts à un
pays il faut aussi leur donner une
contrepartie par exemple la plupart des
des candidats à l'immigration qui
traverse la turquie qui passe en grèce
et de la grèce qui se dispersent dans
l'union européenne vient des pays de
l'est de la turquie est au dessus d'eux
de la turquie donc ce ne sont pas des
monstres à kystes en afghanistan où
d'autres pays de des africaines aussi
qui empruntent ce chemin un turc
parce que traverser la méditerranée
parfois c'est beaucoup plus difficile
mais là on demande l'union européenne
demande des efforts à la turquie mais en
contrepartie qu'est ce que l'union
européenne propose concrètement la
turquie pas grand chose en tant que pays
candidat à l'union européenne à
l'adhésion à l'union européenne la
turquie ne reçoit pas grand chose en
contrepartie donc on peut pas attendre
de la coopération d'un pays à qui on
n'offre rien du tout c'est la même chose
pour la tunisie la libye demande ça va
être quelque chose pour l'egypte ça va
pas arrêter
bon bah écoutez on suivra en attendant
cette affaire merci beaucoup
on continue justement sur ce dossier
thomas raguet s'est rendu à la frontière
gréco turque sur cette rivière evros qui
laisse passer chaque jour des dizaines
de migrants qui viennent d'afghanistan
ou du pakistan
on se retrouve après ce reportage avec
katia gilbert et son invité des images
nocturnes de chasse à l'homme diffusées
sur le web
nous sommes à la frontière gréco-turque
un des principaux points de passage de
migrants en quête d'europe
d'après les autorités grecques trente
six mille arrestations ont eu lieu ici
en 2010 une situation qui a conduit la
grèce à faire appel à la frontex la
police européenne aux frontières
l'objectif principal est de renforcer la
surveillance d'une bande de terre d'une
douzaine de kilomètres où la rivière
evros ne fait plus office de frontière
depuis la ville turque d'edirne 10
minutes de marche suffisent pour entrer
en grèce
depuis novembre dernier 300 policiers
européens sous commandement grec
patrouilles dans la zone
je suis venu ici avec ma voiture de
patrouille roumaine mon travail consiste
à surveiller la frontière
nous ne pouvons pas prendre de décision
nous mêmes nous sommes uniquement là
pour aider la police grecque
à terme les autorités grecques projette
d'installer une clôture barbelée équipés
de caméras pour empêcher les passages en
attendant elle compte sur la frontex
dont la mission devrait durer au moins
jusqu'à la fin 2011
selon le chef de la police locale
son impact est évident pourtant en
octobre nous avons eu environ six mille
arrestations avant que l'opération ne
débute
mais en février nous n'en avions plus
que cinq sens et cette baisse a continué
jusqu'à maintenant mais nous avons
constaté une augmentation des passages
par la rivière
giorgio cela m'agace le reconnaît la
présence de la frontex a eu pour
conséquence un déplacement des flux
migratoires vers le sud
un aveu d'impuissance en somme la police
grecque manque de moyens et se retrouve
incapable de contrôler entièrement une
frontière longue de 150 km de rivière ni
d'accueillir correctement un tel flux de
population
une fois arrêtés les migrants sont
dirigés vers des centres de rétention
comme celui ci à la sortie du village de
filakio impossible de filmer à
l'intérieur la police grecque évoque des
raisons de sécurité il faut dire qu'au
mois de décembre 2010 une émeute a eu
lieu ici une révolte prévisible qu'à
prévu à l'origine pour cent personnes
le centre accueille aujourd'hui près de
400 hommes femmes et enfants dans des
conditions d'hygiène déplorables
ce jour là quelques migrants sont
relâchés essentiellement des afghans et
des somaliens
ils ont tous en main un précieux sésame
ces papiers dit nous devons rester riise
30 jours avant de quitter un territoire
pour l'europe par exemple
et quel est votre projet je voulais
d'abord quitter l'afghanistan
maintenant j'aimerais aller en europe il
y avait trop de problèmes en afghanistan
de travailler avec les américains comme
interprète
je devais quitter l'afghanistan est en
danger oui quand est-ce que vous avez
traversé la frontière
avant-hier et quand vous avez fait
acquis de l'islam
en fait nous avons nagé nous étions
poursuivis par la police turque donc on
a dû aller dans l'eau il a trois des
nôtres sont morts noyés
c'était un moment vraiment horrible
bonne chance merci à eux ne sont restés
que deux jours captif en provenance de
pays en guerre ils ne sont pas
expulsables et sont donc rapidement
libérés d'autres à l'intérieur sont
moins chanceux algérien nigérians ils
peuvent rester jusqu'à six mois enfermés
une fois dehors faut-il encore avoir de
l'argent 60 euros l'aller simple vers
athènes les billets sont vendus à la
sortie et le chauffeur vient même faire
l'embarquement sur place ceux qui n'ont
pas d'argent sont dans l'impasse
les gens à l'intérieur n'ont pas
d'argent et personne pour leur en
envoyer
il arrive que les gens se fassent voler
par d'autres prisonniers ils ont besoin
d'argent et tous les moyens sont bons
pour en trouver
l'ambiance est très agressive c'est
vraiment sale
il est très facile de tomber malade
voilà c'est tout merci des conditions
sanitaires déplorables dénoncée par le
conseil de l'europe au mois de mars
dernier et encore filakio et le plus
présentable des centres la plupart des
lieux de détention sont d'anciens postes
de police reconverti aux fenêtres murées
au toit grillagée comme celui-ci des
lieux que la police grecque cash aux
yeux des journalistes
à l'heure où la grèce traverse l'une des
pires crises économiques de son histoire
l'amélioration des conditions d'accueil
des migrants est loin d'être une
priorité
l'union européenne a donc décidé de
mettre la main à la poche
217 millions d'euros sur trois ans cette
aide n'est pas pour financer la
construction du fameux mur il s'agit de
l'avs dès l'amélioration des centres
d'accueil des mais l'amélioration des
infrastructures de l'aide aux réfugiés
même y compris pour une partie
la financement de l'effort pour le
volontaire depuis quelques mois les
autorités grecques observe avec
attention la situation en italie un
appel d'air à lampedusa
c'est autant de migrants qu'ils ne
tenteront pas d'entrer en europe par la
grèce un répit mais jusqu'à quand en
attendant les candidats au départ sont
toujours aussi nombreux voilà donc pour
ce reportage de thomas raguet sur les
rives de l'evros aux frontières
orientale de l'europe avec nous juan
fernando lopez aguilar bonjour vous êtes
président de la commission des libertés
civiles de la justice et des affaires
intérieures ici au parlement européen
vous êtes espagnol et ancien ministre de
la justice je vous ai vu beaucoup réagir
pendant ce reportage finalement la grèce
a choisi de construire un mur notamment
en réponse à ce problème cet afflux de
migrants est ce que ça vous choque
un mur n'est pas certainement une
solution n'est pas simplement une
politique et par celle qui me rend
l'avenir c'est seulement à l'instrument
pour gérer les présents les pressions
c'est bien plan des problèmes en
appuyant des problèmes en europe mais il
nous faut un euro plus fort il nous faut
une europe plus sûre et une fois en
europe en disposition de remplir tous
les dispositions du traité lisbonne où
ça veut dire gestion de la frontière
comment une politique de l'intérieur
comment est on politique des flux
migratoires
tandis qu'e
il n'a pas c'est du groupe jusqu'à
maintenant c'est compréhensible c'est
instruments mais il faut dire que c'est
pas la solution de l'avenir
alors vous dites ça d'autant que vous
connaissez bien ce problème puisque vous
étiez ministre espagnol de la justice à
l'époque où il ya eu le drame de ces
arrivées de migrants sur les îles
espagnoles de ceuta et mellila vous
l'avez donc directement vécu et là aussi
là bas un mur a été construit en réponse
non pas exactement un mur quand donna
arrivée au gouvernement espagnol les
socialistes nous les socialistes en 2004
il n'y avait pas la politique intérieure
d'admiration il n'y avait pas la
politique commande et gestion de la
frontière intérieure il n'y avait pas
non plus frontex
ça n'existait alors non on a pressé pour
la création de frontex en 2004 on a mise
en oeuvre frontex de 2006 on a fait la
différence
je vous rappelle que quand on est arrivé
au gouvernement en 2004
de 2000 à 2006 on a reçu aux îles
canaries mieux suivre des cyles canaries
on a reçu aux îles canaries 30 et
africaines par an en cailloux costaud
vous étiez dépassés par la situation il
n'existait pas de moyen de faire face
c'est un on a fait du tout on a mis au
travail on a fait du tout on a coopéré
avec des pays voisins
on a mise en oeuvre de programmes de
prévention de la migration irrégulière
on a bien sûr investi beaucoup dans la
gérance de l'intégration des traitements
humanitaire à tout ce sont là on a
construit frontex
on a reçu le problème on en a on a été
capable de résoudre les problèmes et b
non la situation est bien sûr bien
différent c'est fluxs des remédiations
et régulière aux îles canaries ne s'est
fermé ça c'est un exemple on a réussi il
y avait les chercheurs fait de penser
que l'adresse est elle aussi
réussir à régler seul ce problème alors
même qu'elle est en pleine crise et que
finalement on voit bien les états
membres ont du mal à faire jouer le
principe de solidarité qui doit
s'occuper de ceux de ce problème
pallarès tout seul par l'italie de sol
par la france tout seul par malta par
l'espagne tout seul par les îles
canaries pas les régions il s'agit dans
questions européennes dit nature
européen il faut la réponse est européen
il faudra construire et aura des
sentiments maintenant les traité
lisbonne est finalement là et les traces
des niveaux c'est amanda de construction
d'un politique et européens d'
aberration la politique européenne
essentiellement des politiques européens
des voisinage avec les pays du nord de
l'afrique
on a dit on à dire on appuie les mots
bon démocratique
dès lors de l'afrique mais il faut les
prévenir
il était parfaitement pour suivre le
premier que ça devait arriver les flux
migratoires
il faut répondre un clés européens
absolument mais ça ça prendra sans doute
du temps est ce que dans une première
étape le renforcement des moyens de
frontex la police chargée de surveiller
les frontières
ainsi qu'une autorisation provisoire
établissements proposant des contrôles
aux frontières est ce que vous pensez
que ça dans le court terme ça peut être
une solution satisfaisante
en clair européen il faut construire la
clé de la solidarité
il faut construire la politique de la
solidarité c'est dans l'article 81
d'être tel fonctionnement de l'union
européenne
mais il n'y a pas de continuer jusqu'à
maintenant il faut lancer un message il
n'est pas assez stable que la grèce soit
laissé deux seuls qu'est l'italie s'est
laissé tout seul ils le font pour les
terreaux blanc et ça concerne tous les
états membres de même même même les
états membres du nord parce que les
méditerranéens cette question européenne
mais jusqu'à maintenant il est
compréhensible que les états sont forcés
au complet à résoudre à descendre sur
mon extraordinaire
disons par exemple les murs sur la
l'urgence des situations d'urgence mais
bien sûr il ne s'agit pas d'un
d'attention sur devenir la solution du
futur merci juan fernando lopez aguilar
on a bien compris
votre message merci d'avoir été
l'invitée d'europe hebdo on se retrouve
dans deux semaines à bruxelles 3 et de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires